мне тупо не нравится заниматься спортом
Я вами буду делать такой каут у меня
была булимия я дисциплинированно семь
раз толст семь раз худел Вот раньше было
престижно быть качком Давай наймём
человек который меня будет купать у меня
идут похороны тёти и Она заходит и такая
говорит у нас тренировочка если выиграет
то выиграет чемпионат мира я абсолютно
не волевой и абсолютно не
дисциплинированный
[музыка]
человек а добрый день друзья приветствую
вас на итоговом выпуске гемба подкаста в
этом году а сегодня в этом году мы сняли
я не помню 10-12 гемба подкастов мы были
рядом с вами по всем актуальным темам А
много смеялись выражали эмоции говорили
и пытались вам дать много пользы на и я
уверен этот гм подкаст будет особенно
полезен вам в декабре месяце потому что
тема сегодняшнего ге подкаста - это
целеполагание постановка целей это
дисциплина как добиваться того что вы
себе запланировали поставили цель как
сжигать жир Как привести своё тело в
порядок приготовиться к следующему
купальному сезону А как вообще привести
в распорядок распорядок дня свой
привести в порядок как вообще стать
порядочным человеком чтобы у вас всё
было по порядку А как избежать
прокрастинации наладить сон еду питание
А как сделать так чтобы то что вкусно не
не прибавлял вес а то что не вкусно а то
что полезно чтобы было вкусным как вот
эти вещи конфликты решить Сегодня мы все
всё это будем обсуждать на нашем гем
[музыка]
подкасте Итак напоминаю формат от нашего
гем подкаста это Аля кухонные Посиделки
разговоры где через кейсы участников Мы
постараемся передать вам как можно
больше полезной
информации Итак тема сегодняшнего дня Я
анонсировал по ходу А для того чтобы
больше получать информации такого рода
больше получать пользы подписывайтесь на
мой Telegram канал Я внизу оставлю
ссылку Ну и на аккаунты всех участников
которые сегодня здесь они у них у всех
есть аккаунты социальных сетях мы ссылки
дадим
внизу по традиции представляем со слева
направо каждый участник представляется
сам Да друзья Привет Валихан Тен Я
работаю в фитнес-клубе организатор
Алмааты марафона президент Федерации
триатлона в Алмааты велоспорта и
основатель канала другой ты как раз
канал о питании и о здоровом образе
жизни В общем как-то это всё это минимум
то что я сейчас делаю но вообще как бы
вся моя сфера - это здоровый образ жизни
Классно А я ещё гору мы экспертов не
приглашаем Так
блин Эксперт я подумал вдруг маргулан
кали считает меня не экспертом Я 25 лет
занимаюсь ерундой но мы сейчас это
выясним а мы а мы тебя будем на лёд
скользкий лёд выводить мы тебе будем
задавать вопросы не относящиеся к твоей
компетенции и тогда ты будешь не
экспертом А я там окажусь большим
экспертом так дальше Руслан так меня
зовут Руслан хайруллаев Я
предприниматель основатель сети
стоматологии лаб смайл бизнес-блогер
У меня есть также Youtube канал о
бизнесе мы как раз снимали выпуск с морм
ковим в Японии Ну у меня есть небольшой
опыт похудении сем раз на 17 кг
плюс-минус се раз на 17 Да я о
МЦ я сейчас Нашёл свои пищевые привычки
и всё об этом я расскажу Вот супер супер
вкусно так друзья Меня зовут осель
машанова Я основатель клиники Бади мы
занимаемся профилактической медициной
как раз-таки мы про то что нужно делать
чтобы ээ быть ресурсным красивым
красивое долголетие посмотрим получается
у нас это или нет а также мы являемся
дистрибьюторами косметики А у нас есть
своя аптека и Своя ферма Аа У нас очень
разнонаправленные бизнесы кажется что в
них нет никакой логики Но логика там
есть одна это большая система для людей
наших клиентов которые любят чисто
питаться следить за красотой и здоровьем
это такой сейчас тренд вот Вот так мы
построили свою бизнес-системы
ла Всем привет Меня зовут мира ибраимов
я
ресторатор микро инфлюенсер владелец
сети лепим варим по Казахстану и других
ресторанных
проектов В общем
всё ребята я отзываю своё слово что мы
не приглашаем экспертов у нас кругом
эксперты эксперт по спорту эксперт по
здоровому образу жизни добавкам Эксперт
который нам создаёт жиры жиры вот отсюда
вот здесь мы лепим варим Кстати классная
сеть пельменных обязательно рекомендую
сходите я сам несколько раз сходил когда
мы поднимались на килиманджара хвост с
походу мы поднимались на килиманджара мы
шли мира был с нами в группе И мы всю
дорогу мечтали попасть в Алмату на лепим
и варим потому что блин там еда не очень
вкусная мы идём энергии нету силы нету о
чём-то надо говорить и кушать хочется и
мы всё время разговариваем знаешь в
фильме Forest G там был чувак который
креветки жареные креветки вареные
креветки в соусе вот не раз рассказывал
У нас ломоте есть Пельмени такие
Пельмени такие пельмени всякие мы думаем
блин приедем пом и мы это сделали Ну
сегодня гемба подкаст не об этом поэтому
Мы двигаемся Итак друзья первый вопрос а
каждый год каждый год в конце года в в
декабре месяце каждый человек сост и
подводит итоги года это присущее всем
нам психологически Мы привыкли у нас в
сознании отрезки времени делятся на года
год заканчивается декабрём и мы начинаем
подводить назад оглядываться и смотреть
что мы за этот год сделали как правило в
декабре прошлого года ну итог обычно мы
понимаем что в декабре прошлого года мы
неправильные планы поставили То есть это
не то что мы в этом году плохо работали
а в декабре прошлого года был косяк мы
неправильные планы
поставили о том насколько важна
дисциплина соблюдение дисциплины
привычки и так далее мы поговорим позже
а вот о том как правильно ставить цели
потому что первое о чём мы начинаем
грешить о том что мы на себя взяли
слишком много Давайте поговорим о
целеполагании а и мы сейчас говорим не
про целеполагание в бизнесе мы говорим
про личную жизнь конкретно своё тело
будем говорить смотрите своё тело мы
обсуждаем мы обсуждаем энергию потому
что энергия - это то что нас наполняет
то что нам даёт ощущение счастья радости
и так далее поэтому тело Энергия и что к
этому ведёт чтобы у нас было много
энергии и красивое тело что к этому идёт
Ну питание обсуждаем там сон распорядок
и так далее как правильно ставить цели
начнём давай с хана Вот ты в спортзале
видел дофига людей да да Дофига я я я
проживал жизнь Я кстати один из клиентов
алихана много лет лет 20 назад я пришёл
как раз худеть и вот был одной из
булочки который Алихан Валихан тогда
прокачиваю да это Это был первый
фитнес-клуб маргулан Калиевич Нура ки
буланы Это первый это первый кого мы
лепили Но тогда фитнес-клубов вообще не
было и тоже лепим и варим кстати дадада
мы мы лепим мы только
лепим про целеполагание знаете я вот
сейчас вы говорили я вспомнил мем в
интернете идёт и ставит себе там парень
задачу там сброшу 10 кг там накачаю на
стоко там и потом к концу года он там
зачёркивать и меняет там сброшу 1 к То
есть он корректировку делает о
неправильных поставленных задачах знаете
вот Я такой же человек Я тоже ставлю
себе какие-то задачи они касаются
здоровья То есть у меня есть
бизнес-задачи есть задачи касательно
здоровья бежать Айрон Man за столько-то
там пробежать марафон за столько-то там
состав тела довести до этого выиграть
такой-то турнир такой-то турнир но чтобы
это всё произошло чтобы не совершить
ошибок неудачно поставленных задач
прошлым декабрём Я разбиваю сразу на Вот
это большой такой макроцикл разбиваю на
мезоцикл и соответственно например
выиграть чемпионат там по бодибилдингу я
должен в этот месяц выиграть чемпионат
по по рейтингу в этот пробежать марафон
здесь тогда здесь то есть я тогда уже
приблизительно настраиваю свой организм
и главное ментально психику свою чтобы
это не звучало вот так Господи я за оди
год должен столько всего сделать сколько
я не знаю там люди же жизнь проживают
Чтобы это сделать а когда ты разбиваешь
поквартально Ну условно угу Тогда это не
кажется с ног таких с ног таким
сшибательная
то есть вот мой ээ такой лайфхак
разбивать большой это как в тренировках
есть большой макроцикл разбивать его на
маленький вот вопрос всё-таки всё-таки
ставить Большие цели или нет Или я вот
знаете это всё зависит ещё от
ментальности человека
ле А ктото без таких ле жить не может
как и в бизнесе и здоров Тоже самое я из
тех людей которые стат се Большие цели
то есть если выиграть то выи чемпионат
мира если пробежать какой-то марафон то
пробежать его где-нибудь во Флоренции
если сделать Амен то делать Жарких
мала
зах ставлю Большие цели но при этом я
осознаю физиологически свои возможности
Но мне проще потому что я сам спортсмен
тренер у меня соответствующее
образование Я знаю что я могу и я знаю
где я могу сду а где у меня просто может
характера не хватить вот такие вот я
себе прикрываю задачи Вот а физиология
всё-таки ставит ограничения тем более
мне там уже пятый десяток Сейчас давай
сразу я вы будете говорить а я буду
пытаться выдернуть какие-то лайфхаки из
этого Валихан советую так существу два
типа людей одних драт Большие цели други
нужно ставить маленькие цели то есть это
нету единого рецепта зависит от вашего
типа что вас дравит это первый момент
после этого любую цель неважно большая
маленькая
дробитель
пошагово то вот то что я часто говорю
Ешьте большого слона маленькими
кусочками То есть вы разбивает на
квартала разбивайте на месяцы класно я
называю это принцип такой поступательно
когда ты вот у меня же большой
тренировочный опыт как тренера даже да
вот у меня тренируются и
профессиональные атлеты и любители Да И
вот профессиональным атлетам другие
задачи да вот им как раз масштабные цели
ставит Я у меня сборный например по
триатлона по велоспорту есть мастера
спорта международного класса Конечно я
им ставлю задачу выиграть там чемпионат
Азии чемпионат Европы настроиться на
чемпионат мира и Как показывает
статистика Я очень тоже этим горжусь вы
похвастались ли манжа похвастаюсь то что
наши три атлета чем Европы чемпион Азии
то есть мы им задачи ставим и это наши
алматинские мальчишки девчонки которые
становятся такими чемпионами А вот к
любителям к вам да мы ставим мы
вырабатываем стратегию поступательно мы
вам ставим короткие задачи Вот рун
количе давайте мы сначала с вами начнём
приучать ваш организм к силовой нагрузке
нет Мом случае сначала научим вас
заходить в спортзал дышать этой
атмосферой месяц Давайте тогда с другого
начнём хотя бы подумаем о том чтобы
пойти
например когда он ко мне обратится
позвонит скажене надо заняться там
спортом я ему скажу в ближайший месяц
десяточку сбросим у нас будет Вот это
вот это вот это потом бантон это помните
ещ в Советском фильме батон ан там
женщина уже в баскетбол играет Это был
старе
зал он через неделю придёт мы начнём с
растяжек с каким-то и вот потихонечку
потихонечку не нарушая его внутренней
гармонии да то есть он должен постепенно
сну здесь извиняюсь перебью смотри на
самом деле конфликт в чём заключается
все новички как раз-таки хотят быстрых
результатов и сразу врубить в
тренировочный процесс вот эти
растя разогрев вот это суставы вот эти
соен с ми
как раз
качест нго внедрения есть пото когда ты
хоче этого быстро физиология ни психика
человека к этому не готовы Да он сделает
вот кто-то говорил семь раз там
сбрасывал вес в 30 лет с это можно было
сем раз так это
сделать такие Я сам не знал оказывается
есть сегодня такого парня встретил и
когда вот так вот поступательно делаешь
то железобетон никогда этого потом не
бросит знаете вот сейчас три основных
направления Почему люди начинают
заниматься фитнесом двигательной
активностью Первое - это конечно соцсети
все три они рабочие я только за ничего
против не имею Первое - это вот тренды
сейчас tiktok Instagram Facebook задают
тренды мы увидели накаченного парня
который сбросил там много килограммов
красивыми зубами такими Да хочется для
кого-то набрал я худым был ну ну кто-то
ну в общем это всё тренды да то есть
кто-то там но новое течение фитнеса
Пошло все захотели этого второе
направление Почему люди начинают или
хотят по крайней мере начать это удачный
опыт знакомых Да вот НТ у меня пошёл на
кросфит Слушай он так накачался всё я
хочу как он или там подружка у асли там
начала заниматься походами в гору Всё я
буду с ней ходить потому что она Слушай
это антиэйдж она там кислородом дышит
прекрасно вы буду с ней ходить и третье
это к сожалению это направление уже
врача То есть когда уже чтото врач
говорит тебе надо вот этим вот этим
заниматься все три варианта рабочие Да
но они
навязанный вот я это сейчас новое
направление фитнес-индустрии это
ментальный фитнес Я очень сильно сейчас
в это вовч запись на ментальный фитнес
там ничего делать не там просто
думать Надо просто думать это я годы
идут РН колич А вы не меняетесь всё ещё
лёгких путей в фитнес тогда тоже самое
было Вот вот мы сейчас со сели мы
знакомы В отличие вот этот парней мы
где-то виделись но не не знакомы засели
мы как раз в этой теме Да вот в
биохакинг для нас ментальное здоровье
человека даже важнее чем физиология и
вот как ещё прийти в двигательную
активность чтобы потом этого не бросить
вот здесь нужно включить эмоциональное
восприятие то есть Вот первые три Да они
могут заставить человека всё-таки
заняться кто-то останется кто-то
продолжит А вот когда ты просто
эмоционально полюбишь то или иное
движение какое-то и захочешь хотя бы
мыслями туда вернуться как раз вот
говорят о том Ничего не делай хотя бы
мыслями ты захочешь это повторить это
уже считает ты в здоровом образе жизни
потом ты туда вовлечь се я Почему говорю
приступ поступательно с чего-то простого
но тебе захочется туда вернуться Угу
потом тебе захочется туда вернуться с
ощущениями мышечными такими и ты потом
диверсифицировать
быырпах
те хочется эту обстановку потом ты
мышцами начал ощущать что ты хочешь
этого ещ раз повторить Потом начинаешь
диверсифицировать Давай чуть-чуть под
качаемся Да там например или там
побегаем и всё Ты уже там и эмоции твои
основной инструмент того что ты там
остался первые три да могут тебя
привести в двигательную активность но не
факт что ты там останешься Да это точка
входа нефа что ста и
заде
такую знакомые которые в спорте А им
просто нравится заниматься А вот есть
люди я уверен большинство на моей
стороне мне тупо не нравится заниматься
спортом
пожалуйста Потому что Вы не нашли ещё ту
двигательную активность которая бы вас
вот так вот Раз Ну вот
смотри мне нравится играть гольф
классная двигательная активность но на
нём Вот это би не сделаешь но я факт
тому что Что обычно нравится тем людям
которые имеют положительный опыт они
пережили этот положительный опыт в
детстве занимались какой-то секцией и
они помнят эти эндорфины Дофамин там
подъём настроения и у них спорт
ассоциируется с положительными эмоциями
а большинству людей Вот как я например
спорт ассоциируется с работой это пахота
которую нужно
заставлять я расскажу свой лайфхак позже
после всех вас о том как я эту проблему
для себя решаю
сечас Я хотел бы послушать давай не
Руслан а чтоб вот так пин-понг был а се
на стороне валихана поэтому ми Почему вы
так
решили Мы кстати Всегда спорим мы Хотя
занимаемся в одной сфере и у нас
направления одинаковые и мы вовлечены в
эту сферу но мы все Ну давайте так
сейчас я хочу дать Мирас Мирас Нас
кормит ты являешься частью
проблемы Да но самы начать сраться да
Раз уж кормиться надо кормиться
качественной едой Я тут на самом деле
согласен то есть
а мы же начинали Как сказать с проекта
ориентированности Да ну то есть каки там
какой-нибудь молодой стартап и если оно
в какой-то момент не перейдёт в процесс
ориентированность то как бы
а нельзя На вот этом драйве долго
просуществовать а тоже самое Да вот в
молодости Я всегда был худым хотел
накачаться и так далее То есть у меня
целеполагание было как северное Полярная
Звезда да то есть вот есть там картинка
с рекламы акром бифи Я хочу и всегда
происходило Так что хватало на какой-то
срок а потом когда у меня какое-то время
долго это начало продолжаться У меня
сердечно-сосудистые проблемы начались то
есть от торг организм понимаете А то что
сейчас для
меня уже с новым тренером Я начал как бы
заниматься и мне это действительно
приносит удовольствие он говорит Не надо
как бы перекачать вот как сказать зщ
нельзя плохие Да слова говорит до
посинения вот
а и оно на самом деле поменялось то есть
да я не Арнольд Шварцнегер и тут с точки
зрения он старый он старый бгл уже не
явно с не Сравни Мистер очевидно ты явно
не Арнольд Ты не просто не Арнольд ты
явно не Арно абсолютно абсолютно да то
есть Ну тут конечно делится Да есть вещи
которые где я хочу какой-то там не знаю
excellence добиться Да есть вещи которые
не хочу То есть я абсолютно не ты как
вот ставишь цели вот у нас сейчас
маленький отрезок про цели мы говорим на
следующий год вот на Давайте вот
разберём конкретный пример
а сделать так чтобы хотя бы два раза в
неделю регулярно не Как сказать посещать
фитнес и не отлынивать это твои цели не
Ну только по части фитнеса если мы как
бы мы же сейчас один вопрос по части
фитнеса это два Ну стараться Ну
разумеется больше но минимально должно
быть два раза в неделю А у тебя нету
сбросить или набрать столько килограмм
Ну то
есть выглядеть хорошо и неплохо быть
довольным собой что как бы у меня уже
достигнуто
и у
меняло нет но у меня у меня нету вот
этой вот Полярной звезды по части
фитнеса но я занимаюсь други я сам уже
Полярная зда Да я занимаюсь другим
спортом Снукер и я начал понимать что на
простом языке это бильярд это тупо
бильярд это лёгкая форма бильярда самый
сложный такими луми говорите вот с
такими Луза это а это пул это пул а
Снукер с красные Да шари 22 шара Дада
это так у них Луза большая или маленькая
она она лузы очень сложные там
закругление губок можем очень много
технически говорить
а дело вот в чём как раз таки здесь у
меня есть цель здесь здесь по-разному т
всё-таки от приоритетов же зависит Да
фитнес у меня может быть там ну я не
Валихан и не Да я не профессиональный
атлет абсолютно точно да Но что что
касается к примеру снукера Да я хочу
попасть до финала чемпионата Казахстана
потому что у меня уже 2 года не
получается взять мастера
спорта ни для чего это не нужно вот
просто хочу и хочу И что я сделал раньше
ходил в федерацию бильярдного спорта там
есть Снукер сейчас поставил стол к себе
в офис Вот на прошлой неделе заехал и я
вот Неда переехал сменил место
жительства в Алмааты Да я вот машину
зарядил 2 недели назад и до сих пор 50%
всё что взаимосвязано с моими как бы с
моей деятельностью оно Теперь у меня как
так сказать в радиусе там менее 1 км
А я считаю это как сказать очень
классное формирование как бы привычки
вокруг вот своих каких-то Таких вот
целей
Ну Снукер - это вообще спорт спорт
европорт как Шах 24 часа как Шах если
разряды выдают значит нет Очень много
техники Да И вот и очень много боле вот
в плече у меня сейчас происходит как раз
вот вчера тренировался до часу ночи у
каждого пробле
евроспорт--1 то Снукер это 10 крат
должно быть спортом там же не только
сечас бда спорт знаете Олимпийский чем
бда спорт Ну бре данс Может быть спортно
там физики Сколько надо на голове
крутится так давай Руслан а
целеполагание да к моей там к мо какие
ты ставишь цели в области
физики не мы сейчас о физических или о
ментальных вот у меня в этом году был
классно Смотри и ментально и физически
но только не о бизнесе А вот именно
касательно тела распорядка дня последние
3 года я ставил цели в своей жизни в
бизнесе только вот в этом году как
раз-таки в январе этого года я решил что
всё с бизнесом достаточно нужно
поставить вот цели А я поставил чёткие
цели прямо смартик каждую цель которую
делал вот я всегда там слышу Смарт Смарт
говорят Смарт мы на работе де компози Я
думаю вот один раз вот ночью прямо меня
приспичило я заметки начал заполнять и
думаю наконец возьму и красиво заполню
заметку о своей жизни я заполнял вплоть
до женить бы я вот женился Я серьёзно
Вот мои моя команда знает что я в я
нанял нового операционного директора
начал очень много дел передавать
делегировать ещё в марте потому что я
своей команде сказал что я в июне лечу
налаживать свою личную жизнь Всё вот то
есть я сейчас максимально должен выйти
из операционных процессов Потому что я в
принципе в декабре это последний отдел
который мы док это это из планов
прошлого года у тебя Вот на этот год ага
Вот как раз то что мы полетели с с вами
когда снимать это одна из моих целей
была развивать свой личный бренд Я прямо
замерял статистики то есть в Инстаграме
Я хочу столько-то в юбе Я хочу
столько-то мы с вами даже после интервью
общались я говорю как вы вот замеряет
статистики как ведёте там оптимизировано
свои социальные сети дальше Я вот
выставил себе цели Чётко и с Марти
каждую что я за это отдам когда я это
сделаю что я потрачу и что я принесу это
этому миру Я даже как и вот здесь я могу
точно сказать что вот прямо если С корня
брать вот можно всё писать э в заметке
но тут Важно намерение первое Ты должен
вот создать вот эту картинку того чего
ты хочешь я создал по каждому из пунктов
картинку я создал картинку как я же
жениться должен кстати насчёт Жени давай
сразу Перейди к этому женился или нет
женился 3 июня я встретил как раз свою
жену 4 июня я сказал что я её люблю
Через 12 а через 2 недели я сделал
предложение через 2 месяца я сыграл
свадьбу без
отягощать
то как отягчающий они не успели
появиться вот третьего познакомился да
могли Ну в смысле как не о'кей Да
поздравляем Спасибо и я ну это было
намерение во-первых Это я не сделал по
плану да то есть я хотел искренне это
этот вопрос для себя закрыть А ты жену
не определял возраст вес цвет волос
национальность кстати знаете я одно из
ваших интервью послушал и мне это
помогло сделать
ранжирования как-то вам сказали кто
будет президентом вы говорите я не знаю
кто будет президентом должна быть
система отбора да то есть и когда он
говорит Кто Ну там такое давление было
на ин гори Пусть мой брат будет
президентом или друг Да там ну это же не
решит проблему я понял что не решит
проблему Когда не будет системы
правильного отбора для того человека
который должен которого должен
устраивать меня и я должен устраивать
соответственно этого человека Вы не
боитесь ко информационного баса То есть
вы поставили цель НАТО причём очень
конкретный срок встретить его и
получается человек который я сделал в
начале ремарку это моё намерение и
дальше это какие-то нные дедлайны То
есть у меня не было закрыть этот гиш
понятно Да но у вас Значит уже в голове
сидело намерение и у вас мог появиться
конформационные Баско конформационные В
смысле Когда вы видите вы купили жёлтый
Volkswagen микроавтобус И вам кажется до
этого не было в городе жёлтых Volkswagen
микроавтобус в городе Как вы только
покупаете вам кажется что их так стало
много то есть человек воспринимает ту
информацию как внимание начинает
работать выборочно Угу выборочно
соотвественно вас получается вы сказали
у вас появилось намерение И когда вы уже
начинаете видеть вы начинаете
фокус смотри в этом и сила сила намерени
когда ты выстраивается правильное
намерение намерение то ты на самом деле
одеваешь фильтр на свои очки на своё
внимание и благодаря этому фильтру ты
начинаешь видеть возможность
без намерения он мог бы мимо своей
супруги пройти и не заметить я
специально 2 месяца прямо на планёрке за
2 месяца до этого отъезда Я сказал
ребята сейчас нужно максимально Я хочу
освоить внимание с операционной
деятельности нашей работы вот то что на
мне сейчас завязано на мне там было не
так много как раз-таки уже завязано на
тот момент Почему Потому что мне нужно
освободить внимание для того чтобы
решить вопрос с моей семьёй потому что я
очень нуждаюсь
в том то что я хочу обрести Вот это всё
вот всё уже деньги это всё не так
интересно я уже зарабатываю для того
чтобы зарабатывать я должен брать на
себя ответственность за кого-то и я
когда даже писал вот этот список Да как
вы говорите система отбора Да это это
грубо звучит на самом деле там есть 17
пунктов я о них много раз говорил и где
не только всего 17 в моей молодости
женились по любви система здесь чётко по
любви стай я я написал то
что я бы хотел видеть в этом человеке И
что я дам этому человеку то есть там не
было нарушен так сказать обмен да То
есть хорошо всё класс двигаемся дальше
возвращаемся к телу распорядку к телу
удовлетворили мы любопытство в личную
жизни деть не
будем семь раз Дада Не ну тут нужно
понимать что важно знать что ты хочешь
то есть Раскажи как ты вот се раз с 17
кг все ну там от 14 до 17 вот каждый раз
первое что человек когда собирается
сбросить вес тут опять намерение
намерение у меня было такое с детства Я
смотрел всякие клипы реперов ещё что-то
хотел стильно одеваться пузя чуть-чуть
мешает стильно одеваться честно скажу да
и чуть-чуть шнурки подвязывают тоже
тяжко что а и первое что приходит в
голову человек который будет худеть
зашить рот и не кушать Угу это сразу
стресс Это плохо и 700 км в день бегать
Вот и я бегал по У меня есть прямо в
Инстаграме по 24 км на беговой дорожке
вот 3 с по часа Я там три-четыре серии
сериала смотрел Вот так я запарился жить
вот Я садился после Тебе может сериалы
надоели Ну может быть тоже вариант
конечно т в кал там и Я садился кушать
после вот 24 часов у меня вот такой
тремор был Вот я как я не знаю как
наркоман я вот сидел и мне было плохо но
вот так вот я стрессовое Ягу обратно
набирал стресова худел набирал потом
наступил карантин и я понял что есть
какая-то причинно-следственная связь в
этом всём То есть если это ты на седьмой
раз только понял Это я на седьмой раз
понял хорошо что вообще понял ещё все же
говорят диета не работает пищевая
привычка Я думаю Хочешь работает
конкретно работает я пошёл бегать но я
понял что А как тот же самый телефон
заряжается от ватто У нас есть от
единицы измерения ватт У нас есть
единица измерения килокалорий эти
килокалории делятся на Белки жиры и
углеводы когда я понял что нужно
балансировать с белками жирами и углевод
я начал себе сам готовить для начала в
начале когда человек чего-то в принципе
не понимает это становится тяжёлым в
любом целеполагании когда человек
начинает понимать как это работает
причино следственно то всё вопросы
исчезают Мне нужна была какая-то норма я
начал замерять каждый день свой там в
приложении После этого я понял что вот
весы Я думаю опасность у мамы дома есть
я ей купил весы опасность есть ещё
где-то Я просто каждый раз взял себе в
машину Там пять пять по 5.000 там вот
эти маленькие весы Я говорю буду вот
отмерять всё я эту опасность преодолел
там через шесть тире там не знаю там ну
ше месяцев у тебя появляется понимание
на глаз сколько можно есть Сколько в 100
г грудки жареной вареной пареной там и
ты уже начинаешь отказываться всё это в
один момент это наконец становится
пищевой привычкой когда это становится
пищевой привычкой Вот у меня сейчас там
моя норма 7 3 кг Вот я знаю у меня есть
весы Я каждый раз без статистик
невозможно контролировать свои це смотри
получается последний раз ты
схуднути набираю а если я вижу что
статистика Повышается или падает Я
просто вот либо добираю либо доедаю Да
там условно говоря и всё И теперь меня
Мне не нужно быть бодибилдером я подумал
для начала Для чего мне это нужно А
какой-то я Триггер здесь
почка
позвали Алю то есть для чего мне Мне
нужно это во-первых я хотел классно
одеваться сейчас я комфортно чувствую
себя в любой одежде во-вторых это моё
здоровье Вот пока у меня вот так вот и А
вот цели когда ты ставил Ты что вот
смотрите Кстати по Расу как лайфхак
Мирас больше склонен не ставить цели там
сбросить килограммы и так далее он
больше фокус держит на процессе для него
важно сам процесс выполнения то есть
главное ходить два раза на фитнес Да в
неделю минимум два раза ходить на фитнес
всё А какой будет результат он не
парится он главное во главу угла ставит
процесс Вот видите не глобальные
небольшие не главный приоритет по
снукеру то
есть А В твоём случае когда ты худел У
тебя какой целеполагание
было здоровое эстетичное тело всё да но
не было так СРО килограм или внедрить
какие-то привычки нет я я для начала
хотел посмотреть к чему я приду то есть
в какой-то момент вот 73 кг Я посмотрел
в зеркало Я посмотрел сходил к брату
мираса в Ой
вди метабо я тоже ходил
Кассель Как называется им Бади Да
называется вроде тест я провёл тест Я в
отличной там в физической форме в
отличной возрастной группе там да Исходя
из этого я вот это классно и у меня
пищевая привычка образовалась сама всё я
там нача Ну в какой-то момент на бургер
уже чуть-чуть с таким вот недоверием
смотрел он мне прям Искренне не нравился
я отказался там в большей степени я не
скажу что сейчас там раз в неделю в две
недели раз я ем красное мясо там я ем
Обычно я понимаю что мне вкусно в
принципе курицу кушать мне вкусно кушать
морепродукты Ну и я могу себе это
позволить я вот спокойно жи твоя
рекомендация зрителям работает над
привычками моя рекомендация
для начала понять цель потом разобраться
причино следственной связи Вот как по
принципу постепенности Как дойти до этой
цели и и не разгонять её до какого-то
стратосферы то у вас есть цель и надо
понять причину почему она у вас вообще
появилась То есть если у вас лишний вес
нужно понять почему этот лишний вес
появился разобрать на косточки причины
после этого начать устранять источники
то есть причины и эта цель сама
до и она будет Вот привычкой
класс мальчики у вас там цели большие
Шварцнегер я в какой-то момент как
женщина Ну мне уже 45 Да и я понимаю что
для меня бегать прыгать покорять там
переплывать ламан это не вариант
и я задумалась есть ли такое течение
которое
называется
Эне прил один тренер и показал мне одно
упражнение которое я кажется 10 лет
делала неправильно я поняла что техника
- это
всё И вот с этого момента У меня
началась трансформация Хан так на меня
смотрит РТ собака ни разу не была
жеж что вот этот человек пришёл ко мне
домой и сказал У тебя дебели среда Я
говорю это как он говорит ну у тебя не
стимулирующая среда дома У тебя вот
здесь диван здесь диван здесь кресло
стоит здесь журнальный столик здесь
цветочки твои это Это мой дом вообще что
ты пристал это вообще я здесь живу
вообще для меня это было просто шоком я
выложила у себя в стори сказала что вот
мне Тренер сказал выкинуть стол и стулья
первым делом представляете я я сделала
это А почему диваны диваны тоже сейчас
уйдут я их поставила на бедный Арман
бедный Арман Да и он нам поставил
шведскую стенку э маты
гамаки представляете и что то есть
философия здесь какая то Вы конечно
можете в этом в экстриму идти Да как как
это сделала Я Но действительно то есть
спорт - это какая-то разовая активность
которая составляет Там пять 10% твоей
жизни а нужно создавать такую
стимулирующую среду в которой ты всегда
Ну вот например
есть говорят вот
эти гимна раньше гимнаст была Что нужно
когда ты занимаешься спортом тебе
говорят что-то делать Ты должен всё тело
своё активизировать то есть таким
образом выстраивать свои тренировки
чтобы они были максимально эффективными
Ты когда жмёшь ты не так жмёшь да
условно Я не знаю как ты это делаешь Но
а вот так эстетично красиво эстетично да
ну и в общем мы создаём особенно детям
это важно чтобы они были всегда в
стимулирующей среде вот он пришёл и он у
меня сидит на каком-то боссу на балансер
фильм смотрит да или там дети вместо
того что в Айпаде они прыгают и по
шведской стенке лазят потому что это
корпусные тонус у него осанка от этого
зависит потому что они всё время сидят
Они и так сидят 10 лет в школе 4 года в
институте и ещё потом в офисе всю жизнь
мы очень мало двигаемся и это не может
заменить никакой спорт то есть надо
создавать вот эту стимулирующую среду и
условно вместо того чтобы ходить 10.000
шагов я сейчас сижу допустим на Зум
звонках Я сижу в растяжке например и или
не за столом сижу Да сейчас есть такие
стули Horse rid да такие как будто ты на
верховой
посадке и ты
балансируют вставку где у
Марви в доме где вот стоит с вот таким
вот г ноги задира этоже круто да потому
что это Релакс На самом деле есть
специальные позы то есть сначала если ты
напрягся ты должен контур позы делать
релаксировать достаточно правильно
видишь мира это workation называется
между
прочим Аман к этому отно Слушай он ве
день Уста
пони с ним как бы очень хорошие
отношения просто вот интересно вот он
весь день работает Ты скажи сколько он
приходит тебе плачется всё время же да
могу я его не могу сдать братан Я не
сдам тебя же просто вот мне ну как
нормально Ну в приоритете дети поэтому
это для детей якобы делается Да а якобы
Вот смотрите хороший лайфхак мне очень
понравился Сель на самом деле что нужно
создать стимулирующую среду то есть
смотрите у нас Классно вообще
получается Валихан чётко сказал что в
зависимости от типа людей обязательно
постепенно накопительный эффект набирать
это классно Мирас сказал про свою часть
Руслан про свою часть и вот Оселя
добавила
про среду среда почему-то вот реально
вылетает у многих из головы Я вот про
себя вкратце скажу я пошёл я Покрова Всё
я сначала пошёл к Валихан
с ним поработал поработал железки потяга
потом понял да это не совсем про
меня Дальше я начал думать
так мне надо менять привычки Я понял
просто надо менять привычки и причём в
первую очередь пищевые
привычки на любое похудание пищевые
привычки Я считаю 8% влияния озы 20% это
силовые И вот я начал просто исключать
из жизни кофе шоколад мучное сахар и вот
всё начал убирать и самое интересное вот
мне даже отказаться от сахара было прямо
стресс сама мысль отказа от страха от
сахара си наркотик это наркотик это
реально стресс для меня А знаете как
ларчик просто открывается я начал искать
причинно-следственную связь и начал
смотреть Когда я ем сладкое каждый раз
когда я пью чай я ем сладкое Я не могу
чай пить без сладкого меня автоматически
тянет на сладко и знаете что от сахара я
не мог отказаться от сладкого а от чая
отказался на раз-два я отказался от чая
у меня нужда в Сахаре пропала вообще в
сладком пропала удивительная вещ
ряд смотрите оказывается Вот осель
правильно сказала это как раз эффект
рычага когда ты на небольшие усилия
получаешь непропорционально крутые
результаты и у в моём случае это
оказался не отказ от сладкого а отказ от
чая отказ чая на раз-два я отказываюсь и
просто тяга пропадает к любому сладкому
а только вот я иногда нарушаю только в
самолёте в командировках только мне чай
подают Ну блин тяга неимоверно Есть
что-нибудь такое Есть к чаю что-нибудь
такое А почему вы в самолёте от чая не
отказываете а не ну в самолёте это
смотри существует же ещё Кстати мы об
этом Сегодня поговорим существует ещё
знаешь какой Триггер Вот ты в тонус
вошёл всё наладил свою жизнь идёшь
только командировка тебя Пух выкидывает
и командировка - это отдельная Тема мы
сегодня об этом поговорим мозг знаешь
как будто с катушек слетает типа ну это
не считается Да мы же на отдыхе это не
считается Вот вот здесь то что осели
говорит Я считаю очень крутой лайфхак
ребята вот у нас дома например мы вообще
не существует сахара вообще муки у нас
дома нет мучного у нас дома нет молочки
у нас дома нет У нас есть только козье
молоко йогурт из козьего молока дарите и
всё потому что есть не только есть дети
а у меня жена она больше на здоровый
образ жизни Она просто из дома Всё
вынесла нет у нас дома таких продуктов у
нас в нашем мире не существует следующая
мебель не на самом деле классно
оказывается не надо доводить до
состояния Когда нужно проявлять волю
просто надо исключить из своей жизни и
всё вот то что осели сегодня
порекомендовала классная вещь создать
стимулирующую среду супер просто был е я
когда вотже худел бый я там много всего
смотрел Вот эта вот чашка с конфетами
про конфеты если говорит на работе Когда
стоит вот эта чаша с конфетами или пе на
регистрации к рейсу всегда
стоят в офисе а тут там внутренний вот к
офис там внутренний работники и вот если
стоит вот э чашка то в 95% случаях
проходя мимо неё кто-то съест Один раз
зади это вот 95% один раз если она стоит
чуть выше то её съедят 0
если она закрыта под этим то её уже
сидят в % случаев если она закрыта под
ключ то только один про
прямо пойдёт за Не ну и вот то есть
исключить то есть человек если у него
Вот вот что-то есть в поле зрения то он
это обязательно сделает поддастся
соблазну так сказа Классно А давайте
Теперь мы из целеполагания плавно
перейдём в дисциплин хорошо мы цель
поставили соответственно Вот ребята Кто
смотрит на зрители поставили вве с теми
рекомендациями которые мы дали и так
далее вопрос дисциплины насколько это
важно Вот начнём опять с тебя Валихан
насколько это важно Дисциплина и Давайте
в купе и сила воли Дисциплина и сила
воли потому что мы все воспринимаем
опять неосознанная связка спорт качок -
это Дисциплина и сила воли Докажи нам
обратно что
это вот раньше было престижно быть
качком А сейчас вот все все все четверо
раз пару раз туда я тебе наоборот сказал
комплимент В смысле мы обычные люди
сказали Мы не эксперты не качок и это я
говорю это ассоциируется с дисциплины и
воли Дисциплина и сила воли э вот сами
сами понятия Да они уже немножко
человека могут напугать Да когда
дисциплина говорят сила воли это к
чему-то всё это обязывает вот знаете я
вот сейчас такой простой пример скажу
вот нас в детстве я всё время мне
нравится этот пример потому что я прошёл
через это вот я думаю что вы тоже нас в
детстве мама заставляла Зубы чистить Да
ну потому что мы осознанно не понимали
Зачем это надо делать Она гори балам Ну
это потом уже балам надо зубы почистить
потому что ну там гигиена всё такое мама
Святой человек я я не знаю я больше
никого так не люблю как мама и ты всё
равно идёшь потому что ну тебе не
хочется этого делать Я вообще в
Советском Союзе рождённый мы там
порошком вообще чистили это вообще так
неприятный движ потом ты на автомате это
делаешь а потом это уже становится
частью твоей физиологии Ты без этого
просто не можешь это дисциплина Да это
дисциплина потому что это ло
физиологической потребностью
зависимостью в начале да А в начале это
кака Здесь тоже самое двигательная
активность вот два раза в неделю фитнес
Да сначала он поставил себе
задачу потом это стало просто автоматом
потому что я когда-то задачу ставил он
всё привык к этому он уже автоматически
напоминалка идёт а потом он просто э
зависимость Слушай он два раза не сходит
он будет чувствовать что что-то не так в
Мом организме Дума е от фазы зависит то
есть так как
Янь
в начале нужно вот как я два раза в
неделю вот такое то есть Может быть
когда я Есть зависимость от фитнеса
чуть-чуть есть как будто бы хочется како
нет брата Илья Боже я думаю на кого
похож так у них целый фитнес-клуб же цел
инвиктус целая сеть Я думаю на кого
похож и вот это это потом станет
физиологической зависимость и конечно
там уже и сила воли и дисциплина это всё
туда интегрировано оно органически
выливается просто да И вот я атеист Мне
кажется в какой-то момент там уже
какие-то верхние силы на твоей стороне
становится когда ты уже доводишь после
На каком до какого-то уровня Ну вот эти
два раза вот эти два раза я не могу
сделать два раза в неделю не могучем
тебе два раза в неделю когда у тебя дома
даже реби нет Слушай ты живёшь в это как
Тарзан Даль у меня так я для меня задача
попасть в фитнес-клуб вот для меня тоже
попасть неважно что я там я этого даже
не могу сделать просто побывать там
начнём с того потом делать какой-то
базовые Я же не говорю что там сделать
свою лучшую тренировку того дня и так
далее задача просто принести себя если
оно станет привычкой потом перейдёт на
следующи Ты знаешь Глядя на тебя такое
ощущение что ты на первой стадии просто
попасть попасть Да Ты качаешься там или
аэробный
понос Да но правда если у вас вот все
сила воли закончилась дисциплины Нет вы
сдвк вот я сдвк Да и я не могу
сконцентрироваться не могу
сосредоточиться Ну что ты с таким
человеком сделаешь и тогда я услышала
метод манзи То есть у них есть вот эта
Матрица где говорится что если есть
человек которому ты должен заплатить за
эту работу которую он делает
профессионально и получает меньше тебя
Сделай это и в итоге я пришла я поняла
что окажется Я своему тренеру
неправильно KP выставляла я говорила Я к
тебе буду приходить он говорит Окей Сель
увидимся на индивидуалки я не приду он
мне говорит ты где И всё потом говорит в
следующий раз приходи и на этом у нас
всё время мы всё время переносили я не
так и не приходила и в итоге я пришла к
нему говорю Слушай давай сделаем так я
тебе буду за тренировку платить в два
раза больше но ты придёшь в любом случае
то есть мои посещения - это твой kpi Угу
ноль пропусков ты получаешь конце ме се
ответственность сняла на него повес
потому что я сдвк и представляешь что
было синдром дефицита внимания синдром
дефицита внимания и гипер
гиперактивности а гиперактивности потому
что я за всё хватаюсь в итоге Что
произошло вы знаете до какого абсурда
дошло у меня идут похороны тёти и Она
заходит и такая говорит у нас
тренировочка представляете если бы
сейчас вы сидели у меня была бы
тренировка она бы зашла сюда и сказала
ребята Извините о сели тренировка И вот
так бы меня утащила И представляете это
очень круто для таких людей как я но они
тебя вводят в это это режим и через
10-15 раз всё включается вот этот
Автопилот но у меня было так что год я
была
сейчас сейчас у меня появилось окно
возможности интереса к другим видам
спорта я вожу там
скалы выезд на лошадях и так далее
просто и пробую разные виды спорта чтобы
посмотреть что у меня
там так нач дисциплины и во послушаем
вот у кого Дисциплина и Воля вот у кого
семь раз семь раз 17 кг Давай послушаем
сем раз вот я я дисциплинированно семь
раз толл семь раз худел Вот чем Не
дисциплина тоже да А вот Как это ты не
на самом деле я я меня Мама не
заставляла Зубы чистить меня я я
единственный сын вообще я единственный
ребнок В семье и мама говорила Мам я не
хочу шко мама
Гоф да то есть я вот из такой семьи где
вот я делал то что меня любили и просто
одаривали вниманием А во взрослой жизни
когда у тебя большие амбиции и Большие
цели А ну не знаю в рамках субъективного
Да они большие и ты что-то хочешь
большого Ты понимаешь что вот я много
раз там лет пять назад думал вот в армию
может сходить Да на годик вот что-то
меня вот рекомендую Да вот я я об этом
думал а потом я начал со временем
понимать что а У меня есть если есть
сильное желание то мне обязательно нужно
разобраться в этом то есть понять
причино следственную связь когда человек
понимает что-то он начинает к этому
хорошо относиться вот если условно
говоря я вам предложу сыграть в гольф вы
с большим удовольствием согласитесь
сыграть в гольф чем в баскетбол потому
что в гольфе Вы больше разбираетесь и вы
то есть человек хочет к и чувствует себя
уверенным там где он в чём-то
разбирается вот когда я разделил на
Белки жиры углеводы весь свой рацион Я
понял что это работает я понял как с
этим взаимодействовать я начал даже
людям об этом говорить то есть
опять-таки привлекаю внимание что-то мог
рассказывать давать пользу Да тут то же
самое если у меня есть цель Я начинаю с
того что мне нужно разобраться после
того как я разбираюсь появляется энна
дисциплина Почему человек не хочет
чего-то делать потому что он
сталкивается с энной проблемы на том или
ином этапе когда человек сталкивается с
энной проблемой на том или ином этапе
если у него ещё мало внимания то он не
помнит о своей цели то тогда это его
начинает демотивировать И когда это его
начинает демотивировать он
думает Я сегодня этого не сделаю когда
человек понимает что сегодняшний вот эта
деталь или вот этот шаг или вот это вот
поход в на тренировку ещё что-то
приведёт его чуть больше к цели то тогда
он обязательно это сделает то есть тут
Важно понимание и вот когда я я допустим
долгое время думал о я не системный вот
я я реально не системный человек ну ты
системно худеешь дерзко худею семь раз
толст и сейчас системно держусь сист это
уже система это Это как в бизнесе одно
дело заработать надо удержать Да ещё вот
я сейчас удерживаю так вот если говорить
об этом то есть я я системно знакомлюсь
с людьми это моя сильная сторона я там я
долго там сидел в операционных процессах
своей компании 3 года но я долго
закрывался там от соцсетей Хотя это моя
суперсила Да темно сейчас веду Instagram
получаю удовольствие Youtube канал всё
прочее и у меня есть победы победы
победы Я просто нужно заниматься на
самом деле нужно понять что ты хочешь
Угу нужно а проанализировать что ты
реально умеешь то есть каждый из нас
родился с ными способностями и вот как
вы Да говорите всегда усилия сильные Ну
вот просто усилия сильные и это ведёт
дисциплине и это будет во-первых
приносить удовольствие это будет
приносить Т плоды твоих целей и это
будет нести пользу людям
почему бы вот здесь не быть
дисциплинированным всё если я изучаю для
себя новые области где-то в новой
области Ставлю себе какую-то эн ную цель
я первое какую задачу ставлю разобраться
в том же самом браке то есть там тоже
важна Дисциплина и системность И на
самом деле мы с супругой замеряем
статистики того как мы идём То есть я
сейчас
объясню на нормальном языке на
нормальном то есть в браке это важно
создавать что-то создавать для того
чтобы ваши отношения процветали помимо
того что по сюсюкаться и всё прочее то
есть мы создаём
новые там походы идеи да развлечение
друг с другом то есть интерес о на тебя
не смотрит как на странного
такого как сейчас вот на тебя смотрит
Так она не смотрит Она разделяет твои
взгляды ну я думаю то есть статистику
вести Да не ну мы прямо вот так не
замеряем же То есть как неделя прошла Ну
от того что там Мы там очень быстро
поженились то есть нужно как-то вот с
умом меньше эмоционально но с умом
как-то оптимизировать вот эти процессы
классно смотрите получается Если
говорить про
дисциплину разные подходы вот Валихан
говорит надо начать а делать а потом это
превратится уже в привычку в рутину и
начнёт нравиться то есть дисциплина
нужна на начальном этапе мира ты
говоришь по поводу дисциплины что
это что ну у меня другое То есть у нас
что есть в распоряжении время и энергия
меня в принципе не беспокоит что я в
день Ра в день работаю 3 часа в неделю
где-то 15 часов Это мой Вот время когда
я конкретно работаю не всегда есть когда
я прямо сильно там включаю Это перед
открытием какой-то локации меня наверное
с точки зрения дисциплины беспокоит
другая вещь Это утечка то есть там
стримы посмотреть полежать YouTube
Да
тыгы на первом месте
иду Меня это И вот вот сейчас турнир
происходит и я понимаю что сейчас
происходит перебор у меня of Я просто
вот в новый офис куда перее про среду
оставил компютер в старом
офисе буду туда приезжать когда Ну то
есть когда не манчи вые дни поэтому
дисциплина именно само слово мне больше
связано
с таким серьёзным как Валихан говорит
частью вопроса именно вот ограничить вот
эту утечку меня не беспокоит что я там
не вкалываю на работе не Пашу меня
больше беспокоит Ну как бы другая
сторона сторона ты дисциплину
Направляешь на эту сторону Ну вообще как
ты относишься к дисциплине си силе воли
вообще включае я не волевой человек а я
не по большей части не
дисциплинированный человек а я же с вами
как познакомился до того когда же до
Килиманджаро меня позвонили уговорили
полететь кстати очень понравилось всё
вместе можем поговорить но а я смотрел
Кайден планирование 2.0 Угу а курс а
посмотрел совсем согласился
а вроде бы ничего в моей жизни не
поменялось Но я стал расслабленные и
счастливее Угу ничего не поменялось
просто как
а перестал себя как сказать угнетать там
если какая-то проблема появилась сразу
её Зачем Зачем её сразу решать то есть
она же оно потом когда немножко Воронки
там приоритетов немножко Как сказать
утрам буу ется я пойму вообще проблема
ли это и так далее и так далее я просто
стал жить спокойнее и насчёт вот этой
части дисциплины я не беспокоюсь
оправдался Вчера вчера вчера мем
прочитал увидел чувак вычёркивают задачу
из своего планировщика говорит я
вычеркивают задачу она мне не нравится
не из-за того что я выполнил говорит Я
не хочу чтобы она была в
моём в моём планировщике Я просто как не
хочу чтобы она была в моём планировщике
ну я как бы Каждые 6 лет работаю с с
психотерапевтом Ну или как
называется психологом психологом Да у
нас а я просто стал спокойнее относиться
к тому что я люблю Многие вещи работаю
ровно вот Ну конечно не так много но
примерно сколько О'кей
А насчёт дисциплины что меня
действительно там скажем пугает это вот
когда происходят какие-то моменты
перегиба вот по утечке энергии или
времени которая невосполнимая кстати
туда я не отношу ФМ пайс это прямо
увлечение но у всего и планировщика
вычеркнул
Да дада да поэтому вот Надеюсь вот по
вот этой части Больше как-то
сфокусироваться интересно у нас сегодня
все гости у всех разный профиль Разный
подход КК дисциплине воли Но вообще я
для себя дисциплину определил знаете
как дисциплина - это способность
достигать цели независимо от своего
желания и я понял такую вещь я по себе
знаю многие цели я неважно хочу я не
хочу я делаю я делаю я достигаю целей в
этом плане я достигатор и мне нравится
не нравится это не имеет значения Я
просто делаю и всё но при этом я
абсолютно не волевой абсолютно не
дисциплинированный человек а как я для
себя понял такую вещь я понял такую вещь
что успешные люди - это те люди которые
достижение цели превратили в привычку
оказывается само достижение цели можно
превратить в привычку как это строится
вот есть петля обратной связи как
формируется привычка ты ставишь цель
сначала маленькую потом делаешь действие
потом
достигает потом себя хвалишь и
вознаграждает твоя самооценка ты ставишь
цель побольше хочешь ставить побольше
ставишь делаешь
достигает
вознаграждает И когда ты сформировал эту
привычку во-первых Что происходит первое
ты даже не планируешь тех вещей которые
теоретически не можешь
достигнуть второе ТО Но то что ты
запланировал у тебя в голове не
вмещается Как ты можешь это не достичь
то есть для меня Если есть цель я её
поставил и не достичь для меня это вверх
тупости Как так я же это же я
запланировал соответственно Почему я не
должен её достигать я её достигну
Нравится не нравится это вообще не тот
вопрос потому что вы не можете всю жизнь
заниматься только тем что нравится
потому что смотрите даже вы когда
занимаетесь с любимым бизнесом там есть
какой-то компонент который Вам в этом
бизнесе нравится и там куча в нагрузку
идёт куча вещей которые ни хрена не
хочется заниматься но чтобы бизнес
процветал вы всё равно это делаете А то
есть вы смотрите что то что нравится
больше она перевешивает того чего не
нравится
поэтому Нравится не нравится очень часто
дорога к цели она не построена через то
что нравится Это всегда так весы ты
делаешь какую-то часть которую нравится
и обязательно в придаток идёт то что
тебе не нравится Поэтому я считаю важно
сформировать эту петлю обратной связи и
создать привычку и не просто
привычку ходить на фитнес-центр и не
просто
привычку там набирать и худеть а базовая
привычка с детства всем родителям
рекомендую это научить ребёнка достигать
целей А уже не имеет значения куда он
применит это на похудение на бизнес на
на культуру не имеет значения на
женитьбу самая главная базовая привычка
-
это научить себя выработать привычку
достигать целей Вот это из моей
практики Почему я Потому что много
размышлял насчёт дисциплины так как у
меня нет дисциплины силы воли Я думаю
блин А в то же время люди со стороны
говорят что я очень дисциплинированный Я
думаю блин что-то не так Моя оценка
видать себя нев с Например я себя считаю
лентяем люди говорят я пахарь Ну тоже
такой диссонанс Да
и я понял что вот дисциплина Воля - Это
не про меня и я понял что Дисциплина и
Воля включаются у меня не изза того что
я их включаю а из-за того что у меня
привычка я Поставил цель я выполняю
нравится Мне не нравится тяжело не
тяжело какая разница Я Поставил цель я
её достигаю потому что я знаю что в
конце будет результат
я кайфа Я живу постоянным вот этим
предвкушением
дофаминовое интересная такая вещь
что Из своего опыта скажу самое лучше
держать фокус на том вознаграждении
которое будет
позже вот когда ты держишь фокус не на
цели сбросить столько килограмм Аты
держишь фокус на том как на те будет
красиво одежда это гораздо сильнее
мотивирует тебя и держить дисциплине вот
как в твоём случае у тебя же не
сброшенный килограммы интересовали А
именно как ты будешь выглядеть как
одежда и так далее самочувствие кто
сбросил почувствовал Вот это
самочувствие классно О вот это Поэтому
всегда держите фокус не на процессе как
мира а потому что процесс Нет ну для
кого-то работать для кого-то нет но в
моём случае ка вот кайф который ты
получаешь после тренировки Да вот
смотрите если возьмём одну
тренировку сходите на одну тренировку
почувствуйте кайф не
перетруждайся чтобы кайф был а ощущение
мучения не было И следующий раз когда
идёте на тренировку в голове держите
именно вот этот кайф не саму тренировку
а кайф который будет после тренировки и
я себя на этом по мне как-то приходится
обманывать свой мозг я же не
дисциплинированный не у меня силы воли
нет поэтому я всегда фокус научился
держать фокус на том кайфе который будет
после того как я достигну цели А так как
мой фокус там то вот эти конечно по пути
больно будет там ещё что-то будет Это я
пытаюсь не обращать внимания знаете
откуда я это взял я взял это у детей Я
заметил такую вещь я как-то Наблюдал за
детьми которые катались на баллонах с
горки на санках и слушал их разговоры и
знаете что происходит есть же Народная
пословица любишь кататься на санках
людьми и саночки возить Да так вот дети
скатываются и потом наверх когда
поднимаются санки везут знаете о чём
говорят Давай вот теперь по вот этой
склону спустимся по этому склону А давай
вот через трамплин сейчас спустимся А
давай вот это ни хрена они не думают о
том что санки тащат у них всё внимание
на на будущем на том кайфе который давай
Вот смотри Знаешь как классно будет вот
давай вот прыгнем сейчас трамплина класс
и туда приземлимся то есть все их
разговоры идут о будущем кайфе который
они получат когда они кажутся наверху А
в это время каждый из них тащит санки и
баллоны А если бы им там я бы остановил
внизу и сказал дети ваша задача поднять
санки и баллоны на горку а потом
спуститься за минуту всё их Внимание Уже
на тяжести на Санка И они начинают ой
папа может ты НКИ Мне пощи и так далее А
когда ты отдаёшь волю
они автоматически оказывается думают о
том кайфе который будет после а не
нагрузке которую нужно сделать сейчас и
это классная вещь Она работает и в
бизнесе и в спорте и везде а но вы
видите у каждого свой кейс А и интересно
вот мы даём зрителям как раз различные
рецепты это как шведский стол Каждый
выбирает себе то что работает в его
случае а классно Теперь ещ хотел бы
поговорить а дисциплину Волю в принципе
мы не эксперты чтобы глубоко в
психологию лезть и разбираться
А хотел бы поднять такой вопрос который
меня самого постоянно беспокоит Ну не то
что беспокоит Мне не нравится это
несправедливость жизни что почему то что
вкусно либо аморально либо ведёт к
полноте аморально это какая пищ что-то я
такое не знаю Нет ну я чуть-чуть
перефразировал что-то мы разные едм я
перефразировал но есть такое
высказывание всё что приятно либо
аморально либо ведёт к полноте А почему
то что полезно то не вкусно нельзя найти
лучшее из обоих миров вот как вы думаете
Я люблю покушать Я люблю страшно
покушать и проблема усугубляется тем что
я люблю вкусно покушать пельмени да да
Проблема усугубляется в том что я люблю
вкусно покушать и вот меня раздирает вот
это вот как я нашёл решение я скажу
позже вот как вы к этому относитесь вот
у меня нету обсессивно вообще ни по
какому вопросу я считаю что ну очень с
трудом понимаю таких обсессивный людей
которые прям Давай переведу обсессивный
это люди подверженные к чему-то Ну типа
фанатичный этичные да то
есть хочет Руслан поесть раз в 2 недели
бургер е или красном как бы е проблема в
том что он каждый день На завтрак это
хочет есть или на ужин пока нету нет это
нормально То есть у меня нету Вот кстати
поездка в Килиманджаро Мне очень
интересно было В чём я всегда 83 кг
весил Да И вот когда Начал готовиться до
7 ДХ опустился начал бегать 8 8 км в
день Я вообще никогда раньше в жизни не
бегал после физкультуры в школе вот и
один раз я понял я поверил что я это
могу сделать и поверил в то что когда я
ещё раз захочу я это запросто могу
сделать зачем мне там перестать есть
свои любимые пельмени Тем более это как
бы Потри ты любишь кушать обожаю любишь
но нет есть проблема с едой
А сейчас вот
а особенно вот в городской среде проблем
а то то же самое что и с одеждой мы
такую часть своего креативного мозга
задействуем что мы утром наденем и это
очень для меня как бы обидно О'кей с
одеждой я решил У меня есть примерно
такие базовые несколько луков они уже в
школе конечно хотелось или там в
студенчестве быть очень красивым очень
много внимания на на это уделялось и как
только стал увереннее в себе этот вопрос
как бы ушёл с едой тоже самая проблема
что
а поиск еды даже вот сидеть в приложении
в агрегаторе-поисковике
сами скали в начале подкаста что
обзываться можно нет А кстати почему
почему моя сеть успешна при том что я
абсолютно понимаю что там очень вкусно и
так далее и так далее Потому что мы
понятная еда Угу И то есть
а поэтому я хочу наверное Как сказать
следующим шагом сделать так что Ну вот
очень классные сервисы Да по доставки
еды который готовый рацион на целый день
а пока не там не вам вкусно в Америке я
не знаю как всё время спонсорские в юбе
эти рекламы там ровно тот рацион сколько
тебе надо на сегодняшний рацион
приготовить продуктов и нету ещё
выбросов лишних продуктов это ещё тоже
такой как сказать плюс Ну ты смотри
слишком рационализировать В смысле
ты любишь кушать и эта еда тебе не ведёт
к полноте поэтому ты так рассуждаешь да
но меня бесит другой процесс что я думаю
что Вот потому что ты не э к еде всё
равно безразличен
Да нет я могу заказать 36 устриц и вот
просто вот сидеть есть это для меня
самое большое счастье у меня нет как
сказать кстати насчёт целий Да вот а мне
не важно как я
прожужжит я мог регулярно есть трюфель
регулярно есть устрицы хорошее оливковое
масло вообще хорошие продукты я не знаю
в будущем с этим
пищевой
извращение Кстати у меня вообще нет
никакого там тета перед икрой вот это
вот это да Но перед качеством продуктов
у меня вот как сказать я буду знать что
я счастливо Дожил до старости и в
принципе ну значит это не про качество
это про извращение уже что трюфель Да ну
не ну это очень вкусно Я не
могу понятно с тобой с тобой
короче
большинство людей не такие большинство
людей большинство людей едят в лепим
варим вот вот вот
вот большинство людей Вот как я это идм
в эту пельмешку и я ем леми варим очень
много до чех раз в неделю д
ра него гото
ля супер вот поэтому вс-таки надо делить
Почему mcd самая успешная сеть потому
наз может выстроить в любом городе вот
эту дорожку как Где находится ближайший
А сколько займёт обслуживание Какая
будет цена и так далее и так далее То
есть наверное в девяти случаях из десяти
Я хочу свои пельмени Я хочу а как
сказать постоянство чтобы еда приходила
в одно и то же время в одно и то же
место я в принципе кстати недавно жене
сказал Пусть Давай наймём человека
который меня будет купать а потому что
Ни фига себе Ну в смысле я теперь решил
раз в неделю в хамам ходить потому что
вот тереть мне Ну большая проблема
как сказала осель что
давайте не Ну на самом деле мы же шапки
себе не вяжем мы аутсорс это какому-то
чуваку из Бангладеша который делает это
дешевле Давайте аутсорс кто потому что
ну почему-то я не знаю у меня вот на
рубашки после того как я помоюсь всё
равно какие-то Ну то есть приходится
перестилать
Как
сказать пельмени и так далее и так далее
нар с едой не связаны никакие проблемы с
едой связана проблема Вы если про
ожирения Нет я не боюсь я достигал
такого когда мы только открыл леми варим
я 40 дней подряд ел где-то по 50
пельменей в день нифига се 40 дней у
меня даже интервью есть бы часть работы
или Я настолько дорвался реклама была
гот вот такое
лицо дорвался до этих пельменей потому
что я эту франшизу хотел завести давно
когда они только открылись они не
занимались франшизой когда я достиг этой
цели открыл дорвался поел пережил
кайфанул забыл Ну то есть у теб с
проблемой никаких с едой никакие
проблемы не ассоциируются проблема в том
что мы тратим большую часть своей жизни
выбирая
еду хорошо побед а конкретные проблемы
есть давай у тебя почему скажу потому
что дома ложили плов а потом Беш Парма
вот первое и второе вот у меня дома было
так Ага вот мама по сей день вот сегодня
сейчас я после подкаста поеду первое
второе будет Вот я не знаю что-то вот
таким Да я могу
всех Да просто вот то есть я с мамой
долго боролся почему там ну то есть так
много не надо Ну их любовь проявляется в
том как тебя прокормить покормить Да я
потом понял что вот у мамы мамы девять
братьев сестёр их в семье Да а у лда там
лишний раз лицом ой лишний раз там в
компании большой семье вот этот самый не
щёлкают дагу вот поэтому А мама Её
любовь проявлялась в том что она много
накладывала Ну и естественно
образовалась привычка Да много кушать да
то есть жирная нежирная без разницы ты
вот просто наливаешь наливаешь наливаешь
А как ты преодолел теперь Э проблему как
я преодолел и вот помните Да я семь раз
тол сел семь раз худел это же Великая
История сегодняшнего подкаста на сегодня
пер сегодня в этом да да да да да Потом
я один раз я уже вот табах плова взял
говорю Мама накладывает я говорю давай
Мам этот на тарелка на синал ми табах
талань я говорю вот я возьму огромный
табах и я буду есть Ну ты же хочешь
чтобы я был здоровым Давай я буду есть
до того пока вот я не съем вот эту всю
тарелку плова я ел Ел ел ел мама уже
видит всё мне плохо Я говорю что мам как
думаешь я буду здоровым мама говорит
блин я поняла тебя ты не будешь здоровым
Я на следующий же день сразу принёс весы
То есть я пытался вот так объяснить вот
так там Белки жиры не понимает просто я
просто Принс весы сказал всё давай вот
так кушать Ты же желаешь мне здоровья Я
желаю тебе здоровья то есть и вот мы
пришли к согласию после того как мы
пришли к согласию у мамы Супер классно
готовит там курицу варёную вот не знаю
вот фирмен готовит вот о чуть-чуть там
перчика соли чуть-чуть вот так чуть-чуть
лука и вкусно И когда я Если говорить о
том менял пищевые привычки это же на
сравнение же да то есть когда ты то ли я
вот так вот
отмеряют еду когда я её отмеряя мне было
Ну плохо там сухая куриная грудка она же
не прожёг с гречкой Да это стереотип
кочки не едят куриный грудку только
потом потом я начал то есть опять-таки у
меня появилось понимание Да вы правильно
говорите вот цель ставишь в цели нужно
идти любыми способами но ты начинаешь
как-то
это прощать себе и много лайфхаков
сахарозаменитель полка сейчас это сейчас
в магнуме прямо вот этот вот стенд
появился Да там
А там хорошие там мюсли там хлебцы но
нужно читать Вот я потом понял что всё
это фигня нужно читать количество
э калорий Да и белков жиров углеводов
после того как я всё это понял есть
прекрасный соевый соус который не такой
жирный ты можешь его доба То есть ты
продолжил вкусно питаться просто нашёл
заменителей Да я нашёл много заменителей
и там потом начались мифы зачем это
заменитель хуже всё оказывается в
количестве когда ты понимаешь опять-таки
логику И ты понимаешь что всё становится
на свои места вкусно классно кофе я пью
если я захочу Американ два сахара
заменителя лёд растворяется всё шикарно
много Red Bull без сахара Кола без
сахара что-то там без сахара вот таких
вещей до фига я просто офигенно живу за
счёт того что я питаюсь лёгкие соусы угу
Там содержится аспартам сколько его
нужно выпить так ой мальчики я наверное
буду первый Да я первый раз наверное в
своей жизни буду делать такой ками аут у
меня была булимия Ну то есть у меня был
большой вес у меня была
булимия нарциссы маньяки Да И вот у меня
была боле мея и я была на одном очень
мощном тренинге по РПП Я считаю его
вообще супер но конечно там было мало
людей и
п растройство щего поведения это когда
ли Тим поводу того что ь Когда ты ешь
сколько ты ешь ты всё время Всё сидишь
считаешь напрягаешься потом думаешь Блин
как я это
переварюха каких-то эмоций ещё что-то Да
оказывается
твою твои пищевые привычки может
исправить на вершине пирамиды только
эстетика Угу как это выглядит примерно
Потому что когда например вот как Русы
говорил да мы все привыкли плов манты
беж плов манты беж У нас вот это вот
прям фундамент
устаканится Потому что есть даже такое
понятие Как детский референс Да есть шех
повара которые всегда бьют на твой
референс перец Поэтому в Казахстане Не
зайдёт Да Нам нужно всё время вкус халвы
или там пряника или там пельменей и вот
когда мы были на этом тренинге нам
тренер это давала совет прямо задание
она говорит Сегодня вы пойдёте выберите
скатерть Возьмите цветы красивые которые
вы любите поставьте цветы на стол скате
Уберите всё поставьте музыку запе
Камамбер порежьте себе грейпфрут и
сварите себе классный чёрный эспрессо и
насладитесь
и вы знаете это для меня была точка
трансформации когда ты доходишь до
вершины пирамиды в эстетике ты потом не
можешь из пакета жрать Потому что ты тот
человек который кушает утром Камамбер с
грейпфрутом И запивает его горьким
колумбийски кофе красиво представляете И
когда ты один раз достигает рассказывал
вкусно это рассказывает
красиво ещ тр извращенец в кофе пря
представля поте и вот это ощущение того
что ты
сочетает в голове навсегда остаётся и ты
всегда это помнишь это вот как вы
говорите это вот этот вот Замкнутый круг
достигнутого результата И что ты ты это
тот картинка есть ты её достиг ты не та
тётка которая зашторены кушает чебуреки
и потом два пальца в рот ты тот человек
который сидит с цветами слушает музыку
пьёт кофе и и кушает Камамбер запечённый
и у тебя когда в голове есть
складывается эта картинка у тебя все
остальные Твои порывы они об эту
картинку всегда разбиваются И всё И ты
выходишь из этого я вышло классно
Валихан у тебя с едой Какие проблемы ре
руне коне так скучно живу Но я заметил
знаете один момент прямо с начала
подкаста сколько час прошёл Наверное мы
сейчас обсуждаем
возможности альтернативы чего-то Да мы
пытаемся обмануть свой мозг там научить
его как-то двигаться мы пытаемся себя
обмануть там не обжираться или наоборот
есть то есть мы пытаемся найти какие-то
вот обходные пути обмануть свою
психологию обмануть своё сознание причём
у все эти кейсы они удачные он так
обманул Василия эстетика обманула тут
трюфель ещё все по-разному но все нашли
свои какие-то фишки у меня
консервативный подход У меня нет проблем
с питанием Ну потому что я спортсмен То
есть у меня была какая-то дисциплина в
начале само пути моего жизненного и как
это вошло в привычку то есть но у меня
есть много клиентов у которых есть
проблемы
и вот здесь как раз я пытаюсь как сам
любишь куть Я обожаю это вот вот
есть все я не знаю такое сочетание
что-то Я не могу понять Как это
горгонзолу с грушей куша Я даже не знаю
таких вещей половина слов которые вы
здесь Говорите Я не знаю Я качок и мне
всё попроще Да половина слов я не знаю
но я сейчас объясню вообще вот
представление консервативно фитнес
индустрии на то есть есть любят все это
нормально это дофаминовые наши
потребности очень важно человеку выявить
свои потребности потребности бывают
помните как по миде масло самое
незаменимое - это потребность
безопасности в еде там в воде всё такое
Это нормально Мы выявляем свои
дофаминовые потребности все еда
дофаминовая потребность но правильно
закрыть эти потребности тоже очень важно
мы к например к физкультуре к
двигательной активности не можем подойти
с эмоциями если это есть эмоции то они
какие-то порой не очень приятные да а
вот к еде мы подходим прямо органически
сразу с эмоциями звонишь другу там ты
что делаешь жизни Радуюсь жрёшь что ли
жру то есть мы мы сразу еду воспринимаем
как какую-то дофаминовый вот гормон
счастья Да просто и это нормально Это
хорошо Просто чуть-чуть надо включать
ребята кстати рву Если у вас есть вот
эти случаи кто-то решает за счёт
эстетики кто-то не может решить у
кого-то не закры потребности и так далее
Пишите пожалуйста в комментариях это
очень важно послушать и почитать ваши
комментарии мы как раз я хочу посмотреть
вообще и по статистике У кого какие
случаи были правильно ли мы темы
поднимаем или нет Вот и в завершени то
есть выявили потребность Ну вот к еде
надо относиться эмоционально но иногда
нужно чуть-чуть включать рациональность
вот всё о чём мы сейчас говорили про
питание про двигательную активность
сейчас будем сон говорить мы говорим о
путях каких-то альтернативных замещении
но самого главного о чём мы всегда
забываем что то что нам природа дала Это
это даже не родители а природа Да это
нечто сокровенное которому мы должны это
наш организм Наше здоровье которому мы
должны Леле благодарить его до какого-то
определённого времени природа нам всем
одинакова все позиции дала Вот всем нам
до определённого времени мы развивались
у нас был нормальный Ну в большинстве
своих случаев нормальный гормональный
фон физическое состояние психологическое
состояние а потом природа сказала всё
вот я вам всё это завершила Будь здоров
бы а потом говорит вот Попробуйте все
всё вот это вот как минимум сохранить
как максимум это расширить потому что
всё что я могла я вам дала Всевышний
природа неважно можно по-разному
говорить И вот здесь уже Мы должны
придумать свои инструменты как это всё
правильно делать расшить например да Или
увеличить и вот питание - это то же
самое мы знаем что есть какие-то
питательные элементы Да углеводы белки и
жиры мы знаем Из чего и для чего они нам
нужны вообще состав нашего организма это
как дебит с кредитом в бухгалтерии всё
что вошло
соответственно с нашими продуктами мы
должны это потратить если мы не успели
это потратить значит останется у нас
здесь в запасах Да кредиторская
задолженность которая на боках Почему
люди
начинают набирать вес там после 30 лет
потому что сдаем слишком много у нас
эона жено еде превалирует от
рационального воздействия то есть мы
видим что там слишком много энергии Вот
как вот Уру было Да он это сдает седат
сеет потратить не успевая всё это в
течение там суток Двое трансформируется
под хорошо пути как с этим бороться вот
здесь я с Русланом согласен что здесь
должна быть причин естественная связь мы
должны понимать что вся та энергия вся
та энергия которую мы принимаем с едой
должна быть потрачена у нас есть
определенное количество базовый
метаболизм сколько нам энергии нужно на
работу наших внутренних органов Ну у
всех оно по-разному в зависимости от
физиологических возможной у меня это
19900 килокалорий то есть 1900
килокалорий нужны Моему организму чтобы
внутренние органы мои нормально
функционировали
соответственно всё остальное это уже
будет на или уже на лишний вес на
подкожный да или е будет если это если я
чуть-чуть больше сем белка например но
мне надо покачаться это будет на
строительство моих мышц и соответственно
как вот мы выглядим сразу можно понять
кто как ест
Угу всё еда - это источник существования
человеческого организма если у нас
слишком много эмоци не как
Гурман да да как
вообще иде очень эмоциональный подход и
когда проеду начинает логически всё
рассказывать я думаю ты не любишь значи
покушать У меня такое смотрите как я
э ну я не считаю убер это проблемой А
кушать я я всегда любил много кушать и у
меня такая же ситуация мама проявляла
свою любовь тем что она готовила именно
то что я люблю кушать Она всегда вот я
когда-то куда-то уходил на охоту в школу
и так далее Она спрашивала на обед что
хочешь покушать Я заказывал и у меня на
обед всегда это было и Мне всегда
нравилось там и при этом в основном это
самса там белиш Беш Парма манты плов вот
такие вещи ну вся тяжёлая еда и вообще
салатом там не пахло потому что мы жили
на севере там
только в любой пропорции соединяя это
тесто и мясо в любой пропорции это будет
одно из либо манты либо шмак либо
пельмень это тесто мясо тесто мясо и так
далее И когда я женился у меня супруга а
она Супруга с Алматы она больше на
здоровый образ жизни
заточена Ну не то что заточена это Ну у
них в семье так это стиль жизни Алматы
наверно да И она начала приучать меня к
салатам больше салаты есть и так далее я
что за собой заметил такую вещь
во-первых меня блин мерзко было куша
салаты пить Вот эти зелёные соки это для
меня неприемлемо кушать сифуд там
креветок и так далее вообще для меня это
отвращение японская еда это отвращение Я
всё крутился вокруг ма Мант плова и так
далее Потому что вкус детства но потом
начал постепенно постепенно это кушать а
постепенно разбавлять сначала салат
чуть-чуть добавлять там и вот постепенно
постепенно итог я понял такую вещь
оказывается я потом читал и теорию по
этому поводу теории разные оказывается
наши вкусовые привычки то что вкусно или
не вкусно определяется нашим желудочным
соком у я-то думал это как бы ну мои
вкусовые рецепторы на языке оказывается
вкусовые рецепторы на языке они очень
быстро адаптируются и привыкают к новому
вкусу
легко когда ты начинаешь потреблять
много Травы много салатов и меньше
мяса в животе меньше вырабатывается
кислоты больше щёлочи и организм требует
лоч у меня здесь среда щелочная мы мясо
не сможем переварить дайте в траву Дай
траву Дай траву и меняет ощущения наши
вкусовые и я понял я сейчас ем салат вот
будет мясо чебуреки я буду есть салаты
ментально Я помню что это вкусно ну Меня
тянет на салаты Я прямо ем салаты Я
каждый утром сельдерей огуречный сок
который раньше глотнуть не мог по два
двухсот граммовый стакана с утра с этого
начиная утро ем в основном только салат
и сахар не тянет сладко не тянет мучное
забыл вообще что это такое хлеб и
я для себя решил дилемму что для меня
было всегда было почему то что вкусно то
вредно И почему то что полезно то не
вкусно сейчас у меня получилось так что
то что вкусно то
полезно соедини и Оказывается это
зависит от желудочного сока которого в
животе но есть учёные которые копают
глубже Я не хочу дальше копать они
копают глубже и даже есть такая теория
не совсем приятно Она говорит что на
самом деле ваше поведение во многом
определяется теми паразитами которые у
вас есть жи микробиома это называется
микробиом да то есть они формируют
желудочный сок и благодаря этому у вас
формируются вкусовые ощущения и
предпочтение в еде и очень неприятно
ощущать себя что ты вроде
осознан че существо и понимаешь что
управляешь кем-то там это же про это
Роберт сапольский говорит профессор
стэнфорда он написал книгу которая
называется Воля и он задаётся вопросом
есть ли у человека вообще воля или до
того как ты тянешь руку Твой выбор
делает микробиом эндокринная система
нейромедиаторы То есть это не твой выбор
это
выбор я для себя разрешил глобальную
проблему котора меня мучила всегда
почему то что вкусно то вредно почему то
что полезно то не вкусно Сейчас я живу в
той жизнью при котором всё что для меня
Вкусно то полезно нет разрыва Да вообще
нет то что вкусно то полезно а то что э
не вкусно то вредно меня не тянет на
вредные вещи не из-за того что это
вредно А из-за того что это невкусно а
вкусовые рецепторы изменились потому что
всё время ешь ешь ешь салаты и всё время
ешь лёгкую еду а фрукты максимум из
сладкого и всё тебя просто перестаёт
тянуть и Это хороший лайфхак Я вам
рекомендую Я вообще гурман я до сих пор
продолжаю есть Я очень люблю кстати
насчёт эстетики мне это не помогло А я с
детства вот с друзьями даже в поход
везде ем У меня даже в походе белая
скатерть я страшный Эстет в еде когда
мне накладывают тарелку и здесь капнуть
по краям мне не очень приятно кушать и
мне ощущение что как свине
наложили поэтому обязательно мне повар
когда накладывает обязательно тарелку
накладывает так чтобы не кам либо чтобы
идеально вот еда и чистая тарелка то
есть вот это хотя это абсолютно не
мешает мне на охоте есть руками и с
телефонного пакета но факт в целом Я
люблю эстетику в еде мне очень важно как
подают Мне не нравится когда подают
большими порциями Мне нравится когда
подают маленькими порциями когда подают
красиво с цветочками там с веточкой там
розмарина ещ что-нибудь Ну такое
эстетика мне нифига наоборот и вкусно и
вкусно и ещё красиво Блин надо съесть до
конца и кстати вот из привычек вот то
что мама язык любви у неё было накормить
А у меня язык любви Это вкусно кушать
Это первый момент А который сильно
триггернуло и второй момент который меня
долго держал это то что у нас ауле
считалось нужно доедать до конца Нельзя
оставлять вот даже у нас было так крошки
со стола мы собираем надо съесть потому
что Кто съест крошки тот станет богатым
я ел очень много
крошек не вообще очень правильно Мы
производим очень много Вест не я к тому
что это создаётся психологический
паттерн в результате я не могу оставить
еду я съедаю всё Вы помните говорили не
доешь Сил не будет да это не только у
нас европейцы всегда вот сори Да мы
когда вот на лыжный курорт ездим там ты
же угощаешь своего инструктора
получается и вот мы так нам всё это
легко доставалось у нас воду в кран
включаешь вода практически бесплатная
вот европейцы до едят всё до последней
ещё потом вот да хлебом уважаю Ну в
смысле я не знаю это инструкторы были Ну
да когда такая порция А когда тебе вот
столько на наклад и Тыгда не заказывай
будь
умён понимаешь Вот это а привычка
требует доесть доесть доесть доесть
постоянно заканчивается
перееданием порции у нас кстати насчёт
среды мы интуитивно оказывается
двигаемся у нас в доме посуда вся
маленькая кру Вот это кру мы всё по
сокращались кису ки маленькие тарелки
маленькие всё ч Я вот сейчас слушаю вас
Да мне кажется это даже не ваша Победа
Мне кажется вам вкусовые привычки
поменял вашу супругу 100% 100% поэтому
ваши лайфхаки здесь не подходят надо
было вашу супругу сюда за вы здесь точно
не профессионал не смотри я добился
этого благодаря ей но и уроки-то извлёк
я
поэтому важно поэтому
вы Потому что если её посадить она для
неё это естественное поведение а
естественное поведение А для меня
неестественно проанализировали не А для
меня неестественное поведение
соответственно Я задаю вопросом А как
так случилось что я люблю есть самсу
чебуреки и так далее И вдруг стал
травоядным и я начинаю анализировать Ну
вот ваша теория подтверждается для людей
которые вот привыкли самса беж плов им
выйти из этого порочного Круга можно
рядом с человеком который у которого
эстетика возведена да то есть новое
что-то выводи не столько эстетика она
живёт в этом она живёт в этом Потому что
ей еды нет дома жить хочеш она просто
убирает всю вредную еду посуду делает
меньше и так Дале кто Ну вы видите Вы в
партнёрстве это можно сделать очень
круто окружение опять окружение очень
важно Кстати да классный лайфхак Если вы
будете И вообще если вокруг вас все
полные люди то вероятность того что вы
станете полным - это стопроцентная
да это я я ещё заметил такую вещь когда
мы начали ходить на фитнес к Валихан А
мои друзья Все мы начали худеть и как-то
легче было и на фитнес ходить и худеть
легче было и так далее Не ну надо мной
долго смеялись типа Вот ешь бургер и
Колой без сахара запивает Ну хотя бы
экономлю там сколько 34 калории на 100
100 не А вот я как раз смотри я не
сторонник замены сри заме пото что она
как бы обманывает
мозг Но у тебя внутри-то не изменилось
среда то есть замена может привести
легко к срыву вот я пришёл сейчас я даже
в командировках езжу я траву ем и в
командировке продолжаю есть А там же
вопрос того что главное чтобы от сахара
инсулин не поступал ста от Замените но
привычку к сладкому ты сохраняешь просто
заменяешь
сахар
заменителями изменил привычку питания
изменилась у тебя среда здесь кислотная
среда тебя даже не тянет ни на сахар ни
на заменителей базово не тянет О'кей А
вот Представь будет такая ситуация что
ты попал в такую ситуацию где нету
аспартама заменителя сахар нету Колы
ноль есть только простая Кола Ну там
есть тянуть тебя будет тянуть жёстко всё
равно Ну наверное не знаю И пока за 4
года вот прям сильно никуда не тянула
вот 4 года держусь честно скажу Да вот
держусь булганда Вот охота Колу без
сахара вот оно такой привычный мой
напиток Стал вот просто нравится хорошо
я там Я не люблю натуральный соки или
там ненатуральные соки вообще без
разницы вот Кола без сахара есть и Вода
вот это и там ну американы я там не
любитель кофе вот мне нужно Утром ну вот
просто вот есть три напитка которые я
привык пить на край там самый край чай
всё больше мне вот просто вот в моём
рационе или вот э в моём паттерне
поведения там ть питья чего-то напитка
нету других напитков всё нету вода есть
в конце
класс у нас время подходит к концу к
сожалению у нас время не резиновая
Хотелось бы поговорить конечно и про сон
и
про
там биодобавки хотел бы тоже поговорить
Я сегодня потому что это такая большая
Тема Тема биодобавок большая тема
полезные они или не полезные вредные а
усваиваются не усваиваются у меня у
самого большой опыт по биодобавка Ну по
применению и так далее много есть за
много есть против вопросы профилактики и
так далее Короче вопросов ещё тьма Я
думаю ещё на один подкаст вполне хватит
но сейчас на этом надо
закругляться мы по поговорили с вами
почти 2 часа не забываем наша основная
тема была как можно больше пользы дать
нашим слушателям сейчас декабрь месяц
все подводят итоги года планируют год
че а пожалуйста берите все лайфхаки
которые мы сегодня О чём сегодня
говорили
А много этих вопросов и и в плане
личного плана Я освещаю в своём Telegram
канале поэтому для того чтобы получать
больше информации в мой Telegram канал А
если вы хотите больше получать
информации по остальным аспектам вот у
нас участники Наши гости у каждого из
них а аккаунты каналы переходите
пожалуйста к ним рекомендую каждого
участника здесь а а с Вами Мы Прощаемся
Спасибо большое и чтобы у вас двадцать
четвёртый год был результативным чтобы
вы достигали много результатов Но самое
главное при этом оставаясь
счастливым до
[музыка]
свидания